ah
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález los comicios
generales del pasado domingo en alemania
dejaron una estrecha diferencia a los
socialdemócratas del spd liderado por
olaf scholz a la cabeza de estos
resultados solamente por un 1.6 por
ciento por encima del bloque de los
conservadores compuesto por el cdu y sus
aliados bávaros el csv esta fue una
jornada electoral emocionante como pocas
veces ha sucedido en alemania pero el
resultado genera muchas preguntas en
cuanto a la formación de la coalición de
gobierno que en esta oportunidad
dependerá del partido de los verdes y de
los liberales partidos que son mucho más
pequeños pero que se abrieron paso de
manera muy firme en el bundestag y
también es contemplada la posibilidad de
una coalición formada por tres partidos
para poder alcanzar las mayorías los
detalles y ampliación de otros y otros
detalles sobre este tema electoral los
tiene rosa pérez masdéu en el siguiente
informe
el fin de la era merkel tendrá que
esperar tras unas elecciones en que
ningún partido logró la mayoría absoluta
empieza una fase de negociaciones
complicadas que podrían durar meses
según los resultados preeliminares los
comicios se saldaron con el partido
socialdemócrata a la cabeza seguido muy
de cerca por la unión democratacristiana
que cosechó los peores resultados de su
historia la extrema derecha cayó al
quinto lugar y la extrema izquierda
entró por poco al parlamento tanto los
socialdemócratas como los
democratacristianos pretenden liderar la
cancillería pero necesitan tejer
alianzas
[Aplausos]
los votantes han hablado muy claro han
dicho quién debe formar el nuevo
gobierno han reforzado tres partidos
políticos los socialdemócratas los
verdes y los liberales
desde 2017 la cdu y el spd gobernaban en
una gran coalición federal un acuerdo
con pocas perspectivas de reeditarse
ahora los verdes y los liberales en
tercer y cuarto lugar tienen en sus
manos la llave para formar gobierno los
posibles pactos sobre la mesa son la
llamada coalición del semáforo compuesta
por social liberales y verdes y la
llamada coalición jamaica una alianza
entre conservadores liberales y verdes
vive el haber nivel de la gente que votó
por cdu csv quiere que asumamos la
responsabilidad y gobernamos caso
antiguo en neiman y estamos convencidos
de que un gobierno bajo el liderazgo de
la unión es lo mejor para alemania y
tenemos una responsabilidad con estos
votantes las pestes
del anfield flixster liderará el
ejecutivo quien consiga antes limar las
diferencias entre las distintas fuerzas
en temas como la lucha contra el cambio
climático o la política fiscal sea quien
sea el sucesor de merkel se espera que
no sólo gobierne alemania sino que
determine el futuro de la política
comunitaria y el rol de la unión europea
en el mundo
entre otras preguntas quién va a liderar
alemania quién va a asumir el cargo que
deja a la canciller angela merkel que
cierra un ciclo de 16 años con un
repunte de popularidad para ella como
política pero no para su partido la
bancada de los conservadores habrá
gobierno antes de las fiestas de navidad
que rumbo va a tomar alemania que es la
locomotora económica en europa en un
contexto internacional adverso cuáles
son las prioridades en la agenda son
muchas preguntas e incertidumbre después
de esta jornada electoral alemania quien
gobernar ese es nuestro tema en el
debate de france 24 y para analizar este
tema saludamos a paulina astros a ella
es directora del programa de estudios
europeos de la universidad de concepción
en la región del bío bío en el sur de
chile está también con nosotros marcos
daniel maya él es analista internacional
es el doctor docente del departamento de
derechos constitucionales o derecho
constitucional en la universidad
externado de colombia está en la ciudad
de bogotá en la capital colombiana y
aquí en el estudio de france 24 me
acompaña ralph later its él es profesor
titular de la universidad del rosario en
la ciudad de bogotá también en la
capital colombiana a todos les doy la
bienvenida y gracias por estar con
nosotros en el debate ustedes también
nuestros televidentes pueden participar
en este debate con sus comentarios y
preguntas a través de nuestras redes
sociales estamos en facebook en
instagram y en twitter nos pueden seguir
como france24
es en mi cuenta personal arroba sant y
luego les recuerdo que la etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios además hoy estamos de
celebración tres años del debate de
france 24 en un día como hoy hace tres
años emitimos nuestro primer programa
pues vamos a entrar en materia comienzo
por paulina en la ciudad de concepción
en chile
conociendo primero impresiones de lo que
nos dejó esta jornada electoral en
alemania
emocionante histórica y con mucha
incertidumbre paulina bienvenida y
cuéntanos sus impresiones para comenzar
el debate
bueno en primer lugar feliz aniversario
por el programa debate
bueno las primeras impresiones son que
justamente hay mucha incertidumbre
respecto a lo que va a ser estas
negociaciones y si hay algo que alemania
en los alemanes no les gusta es
justamente la incertidumbre y frente a
los resultados en primer lugar que los
dos grandes partidos que
tradicionalmente
han gobernado desde
1949 en adelante que es la cdu como tú
señalaba junto con los bávaros con los
socialcristiano y él despedir la
socialdemocracia hoy día juntos no son
los grandes partidos como
tradicionalmente había sido por lo que
requieren como también señaladas
formar alianzas compartidos que se han
ganado un espacio como son los verdes
que subieron bastante no tanto como sus
expectativas
les indicaba en el principio por la
encuesta y en segundo lugar los
liberales entonces hay un cambio
escenario claro en alemania de
concepción nos venimos para el estudio
de france 24 aquí me acompaña ralph en
el estudio sus impresiones el sabor que
deja a nivel político esta jornada
electoral en alemania para muchas
gracias por la invitación pues para mí
el resultado era algo esperado digamos a
nueve grande su precio está expuesto las
encuestas y básicamente los resultados
para los partidos básicamente
conformaron con con las expectativas por
las
encuestas que tuvimos hay un par de
meses antes o un par de semanas antes de
las elecciones lo que me sorprendí
honestamente era la el éxito como el del
insulto inesperado del de les pide el
ganador realmente desde las elecciones
con estrecho martín margen de menos de 2
por ciento antes de él pero hace como
tres semanas en la despedida estaba de
alrededor de los 13 14 por ciento en las
encuestas entonces y básicamente durante
el verano tuvieron un ascenso tremendo
para haber ganado las direcciones de eso
algo que me sorprendió mucho sí y ralph
aciertos y también errores ya usted lo
menciona el buen rendimiento que tuvo el
spd algo inesperado haber tenido esta
puntuación líder pero también el mal
rendimiento que tuvo el el cdu y su
aliado bávaro el csv que le cobró la
sociedad alemana a esta coalición de los
conservadores que llevaba 16 años en el
poder porque se lo cobran al partido no
a merkel yo creo que es algo que pasa
antes en alemania también después de los
16 años del gobierno dejé muy cool
también era el partido
cristianodemócrata que básicamente se
presentó otra vez para una creo que la
cuarta posible reelección en el año 98 y
perdió y eso es algo que angela merkel
se salvó
yo no voy a presentarme una vez más para
la reelección sino quiero terminar mi
turno y dejar de entregar la carga a mi
sucesor y eso obviamente en alemania es
muy importante porque no entras a mi la
salida del cdu no entro con este margen
de digamos de
victoria del valor albertismo que tú
angela merkel entonces él le cobraron un
poquito su falta de carisma un par de
errores que cometió durante el verano y
un poquito las las deficiencias desde el
propio programa que no tenía unas mitos
como digo unas fuerzas realmente muy
elaborados vamos a dar paso a marcus
nuestro otro invitado ya hemos
restablecido la conexión con él y quiero
conocer sus impresiones y le preguntó
por este desempeño del s&p de ella paso
a darle la voz a paulina para analizar
otros temas adelante marcos bienvenidos
muchas gracias muchas gracias por la
invitación
pues a mí me parece que si hubo unos
grandes cambios en eso porque los
partidos
tradicionalmente aliados y los
conservadores perdieron bastante
antes tenían como 80 y 90 por ciento del
electorado ahora en mi 50 por ciento y
los grandes
que ganaron eran los objetos previstos
no tan grande o esperable y la este y
los militares y yo quiero algo las cosas
importantes
efectos en esto son los jóvenes que
hicieron posible este victoria de los
liberales y los verdes y un efecto de
género que es nuevo también en la
política los bajos 30 años votaron en su
mayoría a la par a los perales y para
los verdes y los hombres jóvenes votaron
para los liberales y las mujeres votaron
para los verdes yo creé este es un
patrón que vamos a analizar más en el
futuro
y también el declive de los partidos lo
que sigamos foxx pata en antes ya lo que
representaron el pueblo la
diferenciación sus
vinos en muchas partes también llegó a
la sal electorales de los partidos vamos
a contar con constelaciones nuevos como
ha pasado en otros países europeos como
una holanda como en dinamarca donde
ahora no hay solamente los partidos pero
cinco y siete barcos no se me adelante
en cuanto a los verdes en los liberales
que ya lo ya le va a preguntar por ese
tema pero antes quiero preguntarle a
paulina paulina y en concepción en chile
la teoría indica que para las
democracias es completamente saludable y
completamente necesario la alternancia
del poder en cuanto a los partidos
llevan 16 años los conservadores
al mando de alemania con angela merkel y
que pudo haber llevado a que se haya
dado este cambio que el spd sea el que
esté liderando así sea por un estrecho
margen
a ver creo que en gran medida merkel
logró de alguna manera desacoplarse de
su propio partido
e incluso en alemania se hablaba mucho
que ella sabía socialdemocratizada el
último tiempo sobre todo por algunas
agendas en materia de
materia familia o en el tema
medioambiental
ya esto mismo de la de este rescate del
plan de rescate rompiendo cierto tabú de
los eurobonos que nos aceptaban por lo
tanto ella como
angela merkel mantenía y mantiene una
altísima popularidad
pero que frente a los alemanes quien
aparecía como su realmente sucesor de
estabilidad de mantenerse en el centro
centroizquierda
y además con experiencia porque era su
ministro de finanzas donde además
aparecía como quien estaba entregando
los fondos de recuperación económica de
europa para esta etapa de la pandemia
era justamente projeccions entonces al
final quien aparecía como el mas
merkeliano de los candidatos finalmente
era y hasta la paradoja el líder de la
socialdemocracia y muchos de los votos
que tal vez habrían votado por merkel
dada su popularidad hasta el día de hoy
sencillamente no votaron por la cdu sino
que votaron por scholz viendo una mayor
o una posibilidad de gestión más
parecida a la de ella y no entrar en un
ámbito incertidumbre que insisto al
alemán ya no gusta esto de de los
desequilibrios o los extremos el
desequilibrio y la incertidumbre pero
claramente estamos en un escenario de
incertidumbre
sobre cómo se puede llegar a formar esa
coalición que vaya a gobernar alemania
marcus y la clave aquí son dos partidos
puntualmente los verdes que usted ya los
está mencionando y los liberales que si
bien pues no repuntaron en los
resultados lograron meterse en el
bundestag con una buena participación y
van a ser la llave clave para esa
coalición a qué se debe este
resurgimiento o no resurgimiento este
surgimiento de estos dos partidos y que
están tomando fuerza a nivel político
para mí si marcus adelante
pues en general la campaña era muy
pocos temas controversiales de hecho se
tenía la impresión que los partidos en
su conjunto
intentaron
excluir cualquier tema
el controvertido entonces es difícil
decir eso era el punto decisivo para su
victoria pero pues tradicionalmente los
viernes de pues vienen de lo de la
revolución y estudian vídeos años 70 con
temas de ecología además de pagar a
feminismo etcétera y en los los
lo que se llama las nuevas élites de las
minas y típico de las ciudades que
trabajan en el servicio público en los
medios
en profesores son su cliente él
y los liberales también
ganaron mucha fuerza yo creo que por
parte de gente que no estaba seguro que
la economía y los finanzas estaban en
buenos manos con la con la serie por los
conservadores entonces eso era clave yo
creo para el éxito de estos dos partidos
ralph aquí en el estudio de france 24 el
punto clave aquí es la negociación estos
partidos como se van a sentar a
conversar teniendo discrepancias en
algunos puntos cruciales de la coyuntura
mundial como la situación económica el
liderazgo de alemania en europa la otan
afganistán
un punto clave el medio ambiente será
fácil esa negociación para esta
coalición usted que piensa no es no no
son negocios son fáciles y las
distancias no son necesariamente sobre
temas de la política exterior digamos de
hecho en la campaña la política exterior
del gran tema menor digamos lo que sabes
es la perspectiva que tenemos acá desde
este lado digamos no sabes realmente y
digamos temas como afganistán o desde
temas de la bota realmente no vendrá
mucho en la campaña esta vez realmente
raras veces alemania aparecen en las
campañas de más del público exterior es
más bien una continuidad no importa si
el cdu o les pide está en la cancillería
lo que sí debido a los partidos es lo
que mantiene a marcos también digamos la
distancia entre el partido liberal y el
partido de los verdes tenemos la
experiencia que realmente está en la
mitad digamos entre estos dos extremos
si quieres llamarlo así y esos son temas
mucho más de la economía doméstica
digamos cómo manejar las finanzas del
estado y también como uno puede
financiar inversiones como uno en
términos de tribulación por ejemplo para
el trigo verde y también los
socialdemócratas proponen una impuestos
a los más ricos de la sociedad que no
les gusta esta idea los a la perdió
liberal y sobre estos temas yo yo veo
mucho más divisiones o digamos peleas y
conflictos
en el proceso de la negociación que yo
espero
no es mi deseo pero yo espero que se va
a durar hasta la navidad hasta navidad
para navidad los líderes de los dos
partidos más fuertes han dicho que va a
haber una coalición de gobierno paulina
de acuerdo a un sondeo que presentó la
televisión pública alemana zdf el 55% de
los ciudadanos alemanes están a favor de
componer una coalición tripartita de
acuerdo al escenario como lo hemos visto
tan fragmentado con estos estas
diferencias tan cortas entre el primero
y el segundo y los partidos que han
surgido y aunque y han tomado fuerza
estamos ante el escenario de una primera
coalición tripartita en alemania
yo creo que sí yo creo que a diferencia
de lo que ocurrió el año 2017 en el cual
angela merkel trató de una una coalición
tripartita que es la llamada coalición
jamaica que en ese momento era la cdu o
la unión junto con los verdes y los
liberales fueron finalmente los
liberales los que se levantaron de la
mesa porque no llegar a un acuerdo con
los verdes y fundamentalmente con los
verdes y esa colisión no funcionó hasta
que el presidente intervino y le pidió
al spd que echara pie atrás a lo que
había señalado en campaña que era que no
quería una gran coalición y eso era
porque llevaban más de cinco meses y
ganó a seis meses sin gobierno y eso o
sin gobierno en ejercicio solo en
funciones y eso trae problemas no sólo
para alemania sino también para la toma
de decisión en la unión europea entonces
ahora yo creo que el escenario distinto
porque estamos hablando de una especie
que no tiene más del 30 por ciento como
era en su momento angela merkel y al
mismo tiempo con los verdes que ya
tienen casi un 15 por ciento
11 7 % los liberales que quieren
gobernar o sea claramente y ayer en la
ronda de los elefantes que es la
reunión donde están este debate que
hacen después de las elecciones
directamente christian lindner que es el
líder de los liberales del fdp de los
partidos del partido liberal les dice
directamente anna-lena board box que
negocien ellos directamente que ellos
vean sus diferencias que están los
impuestos que está en el tema de las
medidas para el cambio climático que
ellos primeros vean directamente y
después vean con quién negociar y
claramente podría aparecer que la
coalición semáforo es decir con la
socialdemocracia sea lo más viable
porque la cdu después de todo perdió
casi ocho puntos en estas elecciones y
el spd logró remontar sobre todo de las
últimas elecciones parlamentarias
varios medios alemanes el titulaba no y
que comenzaba una gran partida de póquer
y aquí empiezan a a
de diferentes cartas y creo que aquí
podemos hacer lo mismo con ustedes tres
comienzos por marcus cuál quiere usted
que va a ser la fórmula de coalición que
pueda funcionar porque él casi que 76
escenarios distintos de diferentes
fórmulas entre los partidos para usted
dependiendo de su análisis su
perspectiva y su conocimiento de la
política alemana cuál es la carta que
usted lanza cuál sería la coalición que
funcionaría
pues yo creo
verdad es una situación bastante nueva
porque los pequeños que no son tan
pequeños van a determinar si cerrar la
serie los conservadores y los
socialdemócratas y no hará mucha
diferencia por esto
entonces yo personalmente debía cerrar
el semáforo socialistas con verdes y
liberales y no dando los problemas en
formarlo porque
pues políticamente son más cerca que si
piensa la otra cosa es si estos
desarrollarán la capacidad de
de enfocarse en problemas urgentes que
no son los temas que surgieron en el en
la campaña pero equipos de larga de
larga distancia para el desarrollo del
país de roja yo mencionó tres partes por
ejemplo de la demografía estamos un
continente extremadamente envejeciendo
en el momento no tenemos
suficiente niños y niñas
la idea es palancia la inmigración pero
no es fácil como parece primero segundo
que es el futuro del nació en el estado
alemán francés español en la unión
europea en el futuro tenemos en la carta
de bruselas
a la corte constitucional alemana que
pide que alemania accede las deudas de
la unión europea correa de comida y los
programas de acá estamos hablando de 500
billones de euros eso es un tema muy
importante qué rol juega bruselas qué
rol jugar jugar jugará en berlín en el
futuro y tercero energía un tema muy
especial porque eso es verdad está su
tema principal es el cambio climático el
31 de diciembre vamos a apagar cuatro de
los ocho plantas nucleares para energía
en alemania
eso es un tema sin resolución ya que es
un país industrializado y toros'
estructuras no jugaron un papel en
durante la campaña pero son urgentes y
yo creo esos eran los temas que hay que
iniciar
con marcos parece que me estuviera
leyendo la mente porque es el tema que
iba a pasar después de preguntarles por
la condición real cuál sería su carta a
jugar en en esta en este póker
y yo creo que estoy de acuerdo con marco
es que la moción más probable va a ser
una colección del semáforo yo creo que
si se van a lograr cerrar las
negociaciones speedy con viernes y con
liberales además yo no veo como amin la
ser el líder de la cdu después de esta
derrota desastrosa de menos casi 9% de
los votos
legítimamente se puede presentar como un
canción una colección jamaica no lo veo
y paulina para cerrar esta tanda el
poker cuál sería su carta
también
señala
además que los tres son los tres
partidos que subieron a diferencia de la
cdv que bajó en las seis también bajó en
baviera y bueno obviamente no hemos
hablado de otro partido que bajo qué
estamos hablando alternativa para
alemania ni la izquierda que solamente
se salvó por los tres mandatos directos
y ni siquiera logró el 5 por ciento
entonces yo también iría por la semáforo
ralph pasó a preguntarle por el caso de
alternativa para alemania que quiero más
abajo como lo estaba indicando y paulina
pero triunfo en dos estados muy
particulares en turín ya y en sajonia
que son del este desde este lado del
atlántico no lo entiende porque un
partido de ultraderecha tiene tanta
aceptación acogida en el este de
alemania dado el historial que tiene
después de haber sido parte de la
república comunista hasta el 89 pues yo
soy de sajonia yo soy de lifesynch de la
ciudad de leipzig entonces si eso es eso
es interesante y preocupante desde mi
punto de vista
el ave ganó casi 30% los votos en mi
estado digamos de sajonia y eso se
muchas explicaciones realmente vienen
con buenas brazos selección por la
dictatura cierto a buena excelente
vivieron la dictatura 3 digamos de la
alemania oriental y básicamente están
buscando un líder digamos de que les
puede digamos salir de su miseria pero
yo creo que esa explicación es un poco
de cortoplacista y demasiado simplista
honestamente yo veo que hay muchas
frustraciones que esta gente sufrió
después de 90 cierto después de la del
proceso de reunificación que llevó
digamos a eso no sé estamos hablando de
30 por ciento o sea no estamos hablando
ni siquiera de una mayoría absoluta
digamos de personas pero hay un
porcentaje significados de esas personas
y de la joven ahí en turrillas que es el
otro estado que donde hace
básicamente fue el partido más votado y
ahí digamos a esta frustración sobre el
proceso mismo de la reunificación entre
varias personas sobre todo a gente que
viven en el campo digamos en las
ciudades tienes otra tendencia dígame
qué usuario live sí y ahí no ganan
partidos de digamos de la de la
experiencia de un normalmente pero ahí
digamos es importante entender que el
proceso de la reunificación también
generó perdedores y unos dan muchos de
ellos optaron por vota voz de paulina
saliendo no es un poco de las fronteras
de alemania
hablábamos de los escenarios que
enfrenta este país en el marco de la
unión europea la relación que va a tener
que tener bruselas con berlín de cara a
este nuevo gobierno cual es la alemania
que la unión europea necesita y cuál es
la unión europea que la que alemania
necesita para continuar por esa senda
por la que han venido en los últimos
años
necesitan una alemania estable en primer
lugar porque
el núcleo duro de la integración siempre
ha sido
alemania con francia la locomotora es
del punto de vista económico y también
del peso político alemania por lo tanto
necesitan en la unión europea necesita
justamente una alemania que sea estable
y al mismo tiempo que sea que esté
dentro de lo que ha significado esta
alemania como parte fundamental de la
integración europea esto todos estos
partidos que estamos hablando salvo
alternativas para alemania son pro unión
europea lo que tienen son matices
respecto algunos temas algo señalaba
marcus respecto a lo de la mutualización
de la deuda pero en general si son están
dentro de lo que es la lógica de la
unión porque además alemania necesita
también una unión europea estable porque
las fronteras es muy complicada en la
relación con rusia la relación con
turquía
la relación con el norte de áfrica y la
relación con eeuu que también pesa joe
biden
tampoco está siendo lo suficientemente
predecible con acuerdo a los cuales está
llegando vaivén con el reino unido y
australia por ejemplo en la zona
indo-pacífico entonces también alemania
necesita una unión europea que pueda
jugar un rol a nivel internacional y eso
requiere estabilidad también y no estos
choques tan fuertes que han vivido con
la crisis sucesiva que le tocó vivir
angela merkel y en ese contexto en
marcus pues el gran aliado y el hermano
más cercano es francia con también unas
elecciones presidenciales que van a
estar muy reñidas a la vuelta de la
esquina como puede ser ese escenario
entre este gobierno que entre a gobernar
en alemania y los posibles candidatos
que se están comenzando a conocer en
francia de caras as presidenciales como
puede ser ese escenario de esa unión
entre parís berlín y bruselas por
supuesto
pues yo creo eso es el la gran pregunta
para el futuro de alemania y de europa y
es muy amplio vetar hay dos versiones y
no es de nada claro en donde andamos
unos dicen
qué es una unión de estados
independientes soberanos que se una más
y más porque tienen intereses comunes
esa es la idea inicial de la unión
europea y la otra dice el estado nación
es demasiado pequeño para en el
concierto global comparado con china
comparado con eeuu
entonces tenemos que unirnos y disolver
la soberanía de los pueblos relaciones
estados para formar un súper estado
europeo
ambos son posibles problemas no son
posibles al mismo tiempo si todos
evitan pronunciarse sobre esto y
balancear los costos y beneficios de de
cualquiera de estos dos opciones yo creo
eso es algo que generará muchas
discusiones en el futuro en el campo de
la política ya vamos llegando a la
última parte del programa raúl fuster ya
nos comentaba que durante esta campaña
el tema internacional pues no fue tan
tan marcado en la agenda pero que puede
esperar américa latina de su relación
con alemania con este nuevo gobierno que
pueda llegar ya más bien continuidad sí
a ver américa latina si digamos en
política exterior yo creo que si el
gobierno en digamos donde los verdes van
a entrar y si los verdes van a ocupar el
ministerio de las relaciones exteriores
eso va a ser muy interesante en cuanto a
las relaciones con china y con rusia
sobre todo por la entonces que ellos
tienen en derechos humanos y eso es muy
diferente digamos el enfoque más bien
económico que manejo angela merkel en
sus relaciones con rusia y con china en
cuanto a américa latina otra vez digamos
ahí no veo muchos cambios con una
excepción de pronto sigue y llegan al ir
a ver por ejemplo para llegar a asia
administrada de relaciones exteriores
eso va a afectar la relación con brasil
se articula digamos gobiernos que de
pronto en el futuro o en el presente
también se presentan como del estilo
populista sea tú no solamente la derecha
de la de la izquierda también yo creo
que
y yo quiero que el partido verde tiene
un discurso coherente en cuanto a
rechazar populismo tanto a la derecha
como de la izquierda cierto entonces con
personajes como bulls o nada eso puede
presentar problemas sobre todo si se
trata de ratificar como en este momento
el tratado de libre comercio entre el
mercosur y la unión europea está
completamente bloqueado y no ha tenido
avance paulina para el cierre no podemos
dejar de hablar del personaje de angela
merkel el legado que deja lo que
significó para alemania para europa que
puede usted resaltar de este personaje
de la vida política alemana que ya creo
que se hizo un muy buen capítulo en la
historia de su país
creo que con sus luces y sombras como
cualquier líder ella es única creo que
es muy difícil encontrar una lideresa
con las características que ella tuvo le
tocó enfrentar desde que casi que llegó
a la cancillería las peores crisis que
se han vivido este último tiempo
partiendo por la crisis financiera luego
la crisis del euro la crisis de los
refugiados los los atentados terroristas
y finalmente la crisis de la pandemia
creo que ella dentro de todo logró
manejar estas crisis en algún momento
sorteo con éxito algunas con otras con
más críticas pero logró mantener esta
estabilidad de la cual tanto se ha
hablado y además dejó bueno fue la
primera mujer que si es que sigue es el
que se demora mucho las las
negociaciones va a superar incluso en
días a cargo de la cancillería al propio
helmut kohl entonces no es menor este
personaje
y que trascendió alemania por la vida de
europa y además barack obama incluso ya
la había nombrado casi como aquella que
iba a tomar el testigo porque
defendiendo la democracia liberal pues a
paulina a marcus ya a ralph les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
aquí en el debate de france 24 les
recuerdo ya estamos transmitiendo 24
horas de contenidos en español desde
nuestros estudios en bogotá y parís y
también el debate ahora está cuatro
veces por semana de lunes a jueves vamos
a estar aquí analizando los principales
temas de coyuntura internacional
diferentes opiniones y puntos de vista
para que usted análisis y saque sus
conclusiones es todo por el momento siga
con la programación de france 24
[Música]